♫ Fanboys Fanboys
♫ The boys who carry the fan
♫ The boys who had a plan
♫ For the way was long
♫ And the day was hot
♫ The boys were always prepared
♫ Neither sand nor heat
♫ Would assail their feet
♫ They did what no others had dared
♫ Fanboys Fanboys
♫ The boys who carry the fan
♫ The boys who had a plan
♫ The Fanboys were on a train to Laredo
♫ When bandits made an assault
♫ But
♫ But the Fanboys fan
made a wind so mighty
♫ The banditry came to a halt
♫ Fanboys Fanboys
♫ The boys who carry the fan
♫ The boys who had a plan
♫ The magistrate said
we're all very grateful
♫ But it's time for an end to your fun
♫ He said to the boys
♫ It's your fan or your freedom
♫ And you may only have one
♫ Fanboys Fanboys
♫ The boys who carry the fan
♫ The boys who had a plan
♫ The boys saw the land
was crying for justice
♫ Yet they knew that this wasn't the way
♫ So they put down their fan
♫ And they picked up their notebooks
♫ And this is what they had to say ♫
- [Voiceover] Though we
lay down our fan this day,
you too can have the power
to unite phrases, words
and clauses with the coordinating
conjunctions of English.
Which are:
- [All] For.
And.
Nor.
But.
Or.
Yet.
So.
- [Voiceover] You too
can harness the power
of the Fanboys.
♫ Fanboys
♫ They're the Fanboys
♫ The boys who carry the fan
♫ That's their whole deal
♫ Fanboys
♫ We're all Fanboys
♫ Remember the boys with the fan ♫